[موسيقى]
كان iPhone جديدًا تمامًا من الشريحة
التي بدأناها بنظام تشغيل
لم تتم كتابته مطلقًا لاستخدام
الإرشادات الموجودة على هذه
الشريحة المحددة علاوة على ذلك وضعنا طريقة جديدة
للتفاعل مع هاتفك
بأصابعك  علاوة على ذلك ، قمنا ببناء
مجموعة جديدة كاملة من التطبيقات ، وكان علينا
كتابة كل شيء من البداية ، فقد واجهنا
مشكلات في كل طبقة من كل حزمة
، كان ذلك بمثابة كابوس ،
ولم نقم في الواقع بشحن بضع مرات
يمكن القول إن جهاز iPhone هو الأكثر
قطعة من التكنولوجيا التحويلية
في العصر الحديث ولكن تطورها كان
محفوفًا بالتحديات وكان II
grunion موجودًا منذ البداية كنت
مهندسًا كنت مهندسًا كبيرًا كنت قد
كتبت مجموعة من البرامج لجهاز Mac
وتشاركت مع صديقي  توني
فاضل وكان لديه شيء يطبخ
لم يستطع التحدث عنه حقًا حتى الآن
وما انتهى بنا الأمر إلى نوع من النماذج الأولية في
الأيام الأولى هو أن جهاز iPod هذا يتذكر
عجلة النقر على iPod ، لذا فأنت تعلم
تشغيل pause pause التالي  هذا النوع من
الأشياء تخيل نفس الجهاز ولكن من 0
إلى 9 تطبيق ABCDE على طول الطريق
في دائرة وقمت بالاتصال وإرسال الرسائل النصية
مثل هاتف دوار كان استخدامه مروعًا
كما يبدو ولكن هذه كانت
محاولتنا الأولى لجعل الهاتف  كان عام
2005 من أوائل النماذج الأولية لجهاز iPhone
، وكان عام ونصف آخر
قبل أن يتم الكشف
عنها للعالم ،
والحمد لله فريق آخر في Apple كان
يعمل على تطوير
تقنية شاشة تعمل باللمس متقدمة كان من المفترض
أن يستخدمها جهاز كمبيوتر لوحي Steve  كان لدى جوبز
خطط أصغر لذلك ، فقد
حصلنا على شركة تسمى
أعمال الأصابع ، ولديهم هذه التقنية الرائعة حقًا
حيث يمكنك الكتابة
بأصابعك على لوحة مفاتيح غشائية رفيعة
لا تحتوي على مفاتيح فعلية
بها مربعات صغيرة ، يمكنك فقط النقر عليها
باستخدام  الأصابع وشخص ما لديه
فكرة رائعة للزواج من تلك التكنولوجيا التي تعمل باللمس
مع شاشة والتي
غيرت الجهاز بالكامل